[Music]
in 793
fearful prodigies terrified the wretched
nation of the angles
in as much as horrible lightning and
dragons in the air
and flashes and fire were often seen
glancing and
flying to and fro which signs
indicated the great famine and the
terrible
and unutterable slaughter of multitudes
which ensued
in the same year the pagans from the
northern region
came with a naval armament to britain
like stinging hornets and overran the
country in all directions
like fierce wolves plundering tearing
and killing not only sheep and oxen
but priests and levites and choirs of
monks and nuns
they came as we before said to the
church of lindisfarne
and laid all waste with dreadful havoc
trod with unhallowed feet the holy
places
dug up the altars and carried off all
the treasures of the holy church
some of the brethren they killed some
they carried off in chains
many they cast out naked and loaded with
insults
some they drowned in the sea
this video is sponsored by vikings war
of clans the online multiplayer strategy
game
it puts you in the shoes of the
terrifying raiders who devastated
kingdom after kingdom in the middle ages
it's free to play and you can team up
with other girls in clans
and fight to become ruler of the north a
wide range of warriors are playable
from mercenaries to horsemen archers to
vicious raiders
as a big fan of age of empires as a
younger man this game successfully
satisfies my primal need
to farm raid and pillage there is also a
recent update
call to helheim which puts a paranormal
spin on things
as a portal to the world of the dead has
opened and revealed many new challenges
so help support the channel by
downloading vikings for free only from
the links in the description box
and become a hero in the world of
vikings and don't forget to look up
voices of the past thanks
in the year 229 a letter arrived in the
capital cordoba
from the governor of lisbon he wrote
therein that
madjus had been seen on the coast of his
province in 54
ships and in the same number of smaller
vessels
abdul rahman gave to him as to other
governors in provinces adjoining the sea
authority to take all needful
measures
majors arrived in seville in about 80
ships
one might say they had as it were filled
the ocean with dark red birds
in the same way that they had filled the
hearts of men with fear
and trembling after landing at lisbon
they sailed to kadith
then to sedona then to seville
they besieged this city and took it by
storm after letting the inhabitants
suffer the terrors of imprisonment
or death they remained there for seven
days during which they let the people
empty the cup
of bitterness as soon as abdul rahman
had news of this
he gave to the hajjib command of the
cavalry
muslim hastened to gather under the
banner of this general
and to join him as closely as the eyelid
is joined to the eye
great chieftains also joined the cavalry
the commander-in-chief made a high hill
near seville his headquarters
and wrote to the governors all round to
command them to call their men to arms
they went to cordoba and the eunuch
nasir took them to the army
but the majors continually received
reinforcements
they continued for 13 days to kill men
and drag women and children into slavery
after some skirmishes with muslim the
majus went to capitel
an island in the guadalcave where they
stayed three days
they then entered kaura 12 miles from
seville where they murdered many people
they then took taliata two miles from
seville there they spent the night and
was seen next morning
at al fakherin then they reembarked and
joined battle with muslim who were put
to flight and lost
so many men that they could not be
numbered after returning to their ships
majous sailed to sedona and then to
kadith
at last when war engines were used
against them and reinforcements had
arrived from cordoba
madjus were put to flight the moors
killed about 500 of their men
and took four of their ships with all of
their cargos
they were burnt after selling all that
was found in them
many were killed others hanged at
seville others hanged in the palm trees
at taliata
and 30 of their ships were burnt
those who escaped from the bloodshed
embarked
they went to niebler and then to lisbon
and were no more
heard of
what is this what is this grievous and
heavy blow and wrath
why is this dreadful bolt falling on us
out of the farthest
north what clouds compacted of woes and
condemnation have violently collided
to force out this irresistible lightning
upon us
why has this thick sudden half storm of
barbarians burst
forth not one that hews down the stalks
of wheat
or strikes the stems of plants and tears
the branches apart
but miserably grinding up men's very
bodies
and bitterly destroying the whole nation
why or how have the leaves of so many
and great disasters been poured out on
us
[Music]
an obscure peoples a nation of no
account a nation ranked among slaves
unknown but which has won a name from
the expedition against us
insignificant but now become famous
humble and destitute but now risen to a
splendid height and immense
wealth a nation dwelling somewhere
far from our country barbarous nomadic
armed with arrogance unwatched
unchallenged
leaderless as so suddenly in the
twinkling of an eye
like a wave of the sea poured over our
frontiers
and as a wild boar has devoured the
inhabitants of the land
like grass or straw or a crop
sparing nothing from man to beast not
respecting female weakness not pitying
tender influence not reverencing
the whorey hairs of old men softened by
nothing but his want to move human
nature to pity
even when it has sunk to that of wild
beasts
but boldly thrusting their sword through
persons of every age
and sex one could see babes torn by them
from breast and milk and life itself
and finding an improvised grave in the
rocks against which
alas they were dashed mothers wailing
miserably nay nor did the savagery stop
with human beings
but all over speechless animals oxen
horses
fowls and others which they fell upon
did their cruelty
extend
everything was full of dead bodies the
flow
of rivers was turned into blood some of
the fountains and reservoirs
it was no longer possible to distinguish
as their cavities were made level with
corpses
corn land was rotting with dead bodies
roads
were obstructed forests took on a wild
and desolate aspect because of the
corpses
rather than because of the bushes and
solitude caverns were filled up
mountains hills ravens and gullies
differed in no way from
city cemeteries thus the calamitous
destruction spread on
and the plague of war born on the wings
of sin flew all round about
destroying everything it encountered
on the 25th of july the whole host of
northmen
forced their way to ram their ships had
not yet come so they crossed the sen
in boats they found there and quickly
fortified themselves
thereupon the rage of the north one was
let loose upon the land
they thirsted for fire and slaughter
they killed christian people and took
them captive and destroyed churches
and no man could resist them
in the month of november the northmen
entered the uas and besieged the castle
the franks had built they cut off the
water supply from the castle's garrison
for it depended on the river for water
and had no other
soon they who were shut up in the castle
began to suffer
for lack of water what more need be said
they surrendered on condition that
they'd be allowed to go forth
unharmed elated with victory the
northmen appeared before
paris and at once attacked a tower
confident that they could take it
quickly because it was not fully
fortified
but the christians defended it manfully
and the battle raged from morning
till evening the next day the northmen
returned and tried to storm the tower
and they fought fiercely till sunset
they pitched a camp
before the city and laid siege to it and
bent all their energies to capture it
but the christians fought bravely and
stood their ground
the guard resisted valiantly and the
clamor of the magnitude arose to heaven
the bishop was on the city wall with all
the inhabitants
the people wept and groaned because they
could not aid their own
the bishop commended them all to christ
because there was nothing else he could
do
the northmen tried to break in the gate
of the tower and finally
set fire to it those
who were within weakened by wounds were
conquered by fire
and to the shame of christianity they
were killed in diverse ways and cast
into the river
the north men then destroyed the tower
and afterward
they ceased not to assault the city
itself
saw how the people were falling into
despair and he went forth secretly to
seek aid from the nobles of the kingdom
and to send word to the emperor that the
city would soon be lost
unless help came when odo returned to
paris
he found the city lamenting his absence
nor did he re-enter the city without a
remarkable incident
the northmen had learned that he was
coming back and they blocked his way to
the gate
but otto though his horse was killed
struck down his enemies right and left
forced his way into the city and brought
joy to the anxious people
the siege had lasted eight months when
the emperor came to relieve the city
it was in the autumn but he appeared
before paris with a very strong army
but he did not force them to raise the
siege
he made terms with them and signed a
shameful treaty
he promised to pay a ransom for the city
and gave them leave
to march unopposed into burgundy
to plunder it during the winter
you